hello everybody and welcome to another
django with python for web development
tutorial in this tutorial we're going to
be continuing to work on our blog if we
go to our home page we find that
everything works we click on blog that
works we click on a blog that does not
work and that's not really aligned with
the fact that we want a pony so how do
we make our blog returned the specific
blog that we've clicked on well what
we're going to first do is we know that
okay the first problem is I'm using the
first you know my site URLs we did go to
blog but this does not correspond with
this right this is start and end so what
we need to do is we need to handle for a
slash and then a number so what we're
going to do first is move the stuff
aside go into blog edit the URL spy
and add another URL so all this is going
to be kind of difficult to pretty sure
we did comma good and now we define a
new URL this URL is going to look a
little scary at first but I promise it's
going to all come together so first
we're going to write it then we'll
explain it actually we might explain it
as we go we'll see anyway what we're
going to do first is URL the URL is
going to be this expression it's going
to start not too bad and then it's going
to have some parentheses parentheses say
hey we're capturing this everything here
inside these parentheses question mark P
capital P there this is a named
capturing group if you let's pull up the
Django here you can come over here and
read more about named groups this link
will be in the description as far as
capturing that group but that basically
what we're doing there the reason why we
want to be able to do that is because
we're going to grab specifically by each
post ID and then also we're grabbing
right in between these parentheses
very specific you'll understand here in
a moment let me move this up just
understand the question mark P
corresponds to named groups the next
thing is in these brackets we put P K
this PK stands for primary key and as
you've seen already the primary key is
that ID column so that's the first
column in our table basically in every
post gets a unique primary key this is
like starts at zero it's auto
incrementing so it's like zero one two
three four five all the way up to
however many posts you have so that
primary key is quite specifically is
this right here right we're trying to
get to the prat the blog information
that is of the primary key of one so
primary key there and then that primary
key is a backslash D which corresponds
to being a digit in regular expressions
and then we use a plus now if you're not
familiar with regular expressions like I
said before you can go to Python
programming at net let me just pull an
up real quick and we'll research with
that regular expressions with Python we
can come on down to here and we see a
plus is matches one or more so when we
have a / D plus that means it's a digit
and it's either one or more digits okay
so one to a billion will be acceptable
here and beyond a billion of course okay
so um then that's what we're capturing
here basically and then end so basically
what this is saying here is the URL
begins and again of course that's
beginning after /blog right because the
what's happening here is slash blog
leads us to this urls dot pi and then
from here is what we define so slash
blog and then theory slash and then
you've got this information here and
then it ends well this information here
as long as it is is just saying hey
the primary key which happens to be a
digit you don't actually have to have
digit there but you want to do that
because you're you know the primary key
is supposed to be a digit and if the
users trying to get some lols they might
try to do hacky things on your website
one of those things might be instead of
having a primary key maybe put a string
maybe put an SQL query in there just to
see because what's happening is it's
going to query the database for that
primary key so then the you know want to
be hacker might say like Oh hmm the
primary key is mm I don't know a
quotation closing and drop table
where's the yeah so they might try to
you know play play games so so we're
going to say that this has to be a digit
otherwise don't return anything and not
that that would have worked just saying
Django is a little smarter than that but
just keep that in mind
so now comma and then instead of list
view this is a detail view so detail
view and dot as underscore view and then
the model we're going to have for this
detail view is post just that post class
from the models and then template
underscore name is going to be equal to
blog slash post HTML so the model
already exists we created that long ago
in a previous decade and then the
template name obviously this doesn't
exist we need to create that so that's
what we're going to do now so let's go
ahead and save this exit the URL spy and
come into templates blog and now just
copy blog and then I'm going to rename
it to be post ID CH tml and oops I knew
I told you I warned you about that
initially on probably other operating
systems you might not be as likely to do
that but on Windows I do that all the
time and it was no bad no and closes and
zoom it zoom in please thank you sir
okay this will indeed extend personal
header it's going to have block content
and that's where it stops so
do this and so this is the individual
blog page so how do we want that
individual blog page to look you can
obviously do a whole lot of things we're
going to say the title will be in header
three tags and to do that um I could put
a link to the title but that's kind of
redundant so I would probably just say
literally post title here and then you
would obviously break here and then
maybe below the post you would say like
when was it published
so header six tags and then in here
actually before the variables you would
say on space and then post date so that
was the date it was posted and then from
there we would have like the body so
we'll put the body let's do a variable
there and then what we can say here is
post off body we're saying all these
posts these the posts that are coming
from us right this is coming from our
admin page okay so for admin page is
compromised
we got props so we're gonna say a filter
safe so this is like a safe basically
what this does is it allows us to put
HTML into the Jinja so if you didn't
have this and you said in your post was
um had paragraph tags and and strong to
make things bold and stuff like that if
you didn't put slash safe it would come
through as plain text tags if that
doesn't make any sense to you if I
remember to show you I'll show you what
what what I mean there and then again
we'll do another bar and line breaks so
every time there's a line break there
will be a line break okay that's our
post body no problem and that should be
everything we need really let's just tap
this over save and we should be ready to
rumble let's come over here everything
looks good there let's bring up our
website here yeah refresh and here's our
blog so erm
Django is awesome everything's there so
we click on blog click another one hello
world hiya blog amazing and so on
amazing grace
okay so so now let us head to whoops
head to our admin page oops
admin and let's add a new blog and hey
there and then we'll say let's put
something in header one tags giant text
okay and we'll say today now and we'll
save that and so it exists we can click
on it read it cool but mainly what we're
going to look at is go back here click
blog this one and it says you know hey
there giant text what happens if we did
not say this text was safe we do this
save that
come over here refresh and you get the
plain text values right these are you
know and if you view the source you'll
see that they were changed here so let's
go here and you'll see that yet you get
these little the convertor basically
that's so it's not the actual tag so so
that's what safe does there are a lot of
other filters and stuff like that with
Jinja and we can cover those at a later
later tutorial but just know that that's
what you can do and so so now when you
go to post your blog not only can you
use like header tags you do like image
tags you can do scripts you can do all
kinds of stuff and because you can do
things like scripts that's why if say
you've got a forum and you're allowing
users to post you probably don't want to
say that that text is safe because
they're going to be putting all kinds of
stuff in there so so that's kind of why
by default Django is not going to treat
that as Raj tml they're going to do
converts and escape things and stuff
like that in your favor but since it's
coming from the admin page write your
posts are all coming from admin we're
going to go ahead and say hey that's
some safe information okay so at this
point you now have your homepage or your
you know really your about me page you
can put some information here you got a
contact information and you've got even
a blog that you can add things to of
course your blog is
not pretty it's not the best-looking
blog in the world so I highly suggest
you would spice this up a little bit and
you're really your whole personal
website it's not very attractive yet
also the link standing here obviously
don't really work they just lead to
nothing but you could populate those so
I suggest you spend some time on
bootstrap especially if you do end up
you know pushing this live and all that
so if you have questions comments
concerns whatever up into this point
feel free to leave them below otherwise
as always thanks for watching thanks for
all the support subscriptions and until
next time